une livraison d'urgence
Ottawa n'a plus le choix devant la
pénurie début profane et
d'acétaminophène pour enfants il se
tourne vers l'étranger un million de
bouteilles d'analgésiques seront
importés les 10 usines canadiennes de
production de ces produits
pharmaceutiques ne fournissent plus la
production nationale est normalement de
5 à 6000 unités par mois et fabricant
pour atteindre des niveaux records mais
la demande a continué d'accroître et à
grandement dépasser l’offre les
premières quantités seront livrées aux
hôpitaux pédiatriques partout au pays
leurs urgences débordent d'enfants
atteints de virus respiratoires dans la
capitale nationale une deuxième unité
temporaire de soins intensifs sera créé
en attendant on transfère certains
enfants malades dans les hôpitaux de
Kingston situé à plus de deux heures
d'Ottawa en étant en train de planifier
si nécessaire l'ouverture va encore plus
de lit incroyablement
irresponsable pour l'opposition cette
solution ne viendra pas à bout la
pénurie il faut qu'on soit capable de
produire des médicaments ici au Canada
le gouvernement n'a rien fait là-dessus
le gouvernement semble réagir trop tard
pour un million de bouteilles reste à
voir pour la grandeur du Canada d'un
océan à l'autre reste à voir si ça vous
suffit ils sont toujours vague dans la
réplique dans les semaines prochaines la
semaine prochaine des choses comme ça
les parents ils venaient une date le
gouvernement promet que d'ici 2 à 3
semaines les parents verront de nouveau
des tablettes pleines à la pharmacie et
les invite à ne pas acheter plus de
produits qu'ils en ont besoin car la
pénurie n'est pas prête de se résorber
ici Marie-José paquet de Comores au
Canada
Ottawa